[Music]
we have built an organization here at
the MIT Media Lab that is very
deliberately set up to allow people to
collaborate across disciplines one great
advantage of the Media Lab is there are
many disciplines each with a different
focus so there's a sharing of ideas that
is rare the good stuff is between these
various disciplines not within humans
have always been social animals
our ancestors use signals to communicate
to form into groups to hunt to protect
themselves to feed the young to have fun
so when we look at actual groups and
measure them what we find is that the
most important effect is does everybody
contribute more or less equally that is
almost 50% of the performance of the
group people often ask me what is it
that I'm supposed to do to be part of an
effective team what are sort of the
bullet points to remember the first one
is communicating frequently keep
everybody in the loop the second one is
you have to have everybody engaged means
you have to talk your share and listen
to everybody else and you should
acknowledge when somebody says something
interesting also communication is not
just about the strategy in the topic
it's about building social ties about
understanding the contexts so you need
social communication to complement the
business communication and the final one
is you need to understand the context of
your workgroup which means you need to
talk to the rest of the people in the
organization too over time we've been so
successful that we've seen the rest of
MIT convert to this one of the most
interesting groups around here is the
changing places group and they're
interested in how do you build
architecture to support more innovation
we have to become more innovative to
deal with big challenges like pollution
and global warming and what you find is
by changing the way the neighborhood
runs you can make the neighborhood work
a lot lot better
we're working on urban modeling and
simulation we're using Lego bricks and
projection with augmented reality it's
the intermingling of the knowledge and
experience of designers with people that
really understand the technology and
what's possible so one can look at
changes in density changes in the
location of elements new types of
mobility systems you start with data
visualization so for example the
movement patterns of people so we can
take that kind of information and think
about how to provide alternative ways of
getting around to private automobiles
there's an interesting correlation
between conditions like heart disease
and diabetes obesity and people's
proximity to parks and bike lanes and
more walkable communities so we think we
can begin to quantify the impact of
design on wellness a designer alone
couldn't put together a tool like the
city scope and at computer scientist or
an engineer couldn't put together a tool
like that because it's informed by both
the needs for working through a complex
design problem and also it makes use of
very complex technology in the future
what you're going to see is smaller more
agile groups that are coordinated using
fairly rich data how could we build
better governments better organizations
better families by recognizing that the
social fabric between us is at least as
important as the individuality